okay the Miss America beauty pageant
will no longer be a beauty pageant it
will be a competition the organization
announced today in a statement we are no
longer a pageant Miss America will
represent a new generation of female
leaders focused on scholarship social
impact talent and empowerment but this
competition will not include the
swimsuit competition with the
organization stating it quote will no
longer judge our candidates on their
outward physical appearance well let's
debate this wisdom of these things with
Madison Jessie OTO a former Miss Ohio in
the Miss USA pageant all right now this
is wild because if Madison outward
appearance has no relevance whatsoever
to this whole thing then why don't you
just do it like on the radio what can't
it just be a radio Conor radio show and
a caller called in today and made that
comment I was screaming laughing I'm
like you could have just didn't have to
do the makeup the hair just just just
talk
no they're exactly right I'm not
impressed with what Miss America
Organization has decided to do and when
you look in the dictionary at the actual
definition of pageant it's a beauty
contest and of course outward beauty is
not as important as inner beauty but at
the same time it doesn't mean that outer
beauty can't exist and that women should
be shamed or banned from being able to
express themselves and feel confident
have a positive body image and show off
their physical fitness there's nothing
wrong with that no one's forced to
compete in Miss USA or Miss America and
there's literally nothing left not only
did they eliminate swimsuit they took
away evening gown - oh no I think
they're gonna alter it even go even
Galan can help you anything you want you
just wear an outfit you can wear
athleisure if you feel like that's the
point one of the worst don't know so it
I know I didn't know that it was in the
90s is when the there was a the bikini
started so it was like 97 I think they
started doing the bikinis which yeah you
know the men like it but you know it's a
little much on the bikini but the the
one-piece I thought those really pretty
and dignified and also sexy attractive
but what is this about this is the me to
thing don't don't hate us because we're
beautiful thing I like what is it I
don't even understand I can't
and coop up with the feminist movement
of me too when it comes to the
relationship to pageants because the
first thing they were saying is that
women should be a powered able to wear
whatever they want now all of a sudden
women should not be able to wear
whatever they want I can't keep up it's
ridiculous they're totally off-base
they make no sense and I don't think
they're really making positive impact on
the me to movement with this region I
also think that in a way they're
implicitly casting aspersions on people
like you now you are Miss Ohio for in
Miss USA pageant and you're you just
took the bar passed the bar
congratulations yeah awesome thank you
you're gonna go on be a lawyer and and
so many people who are in these pageants
competitions go on to do incredible fast
as maybe there are professional moms
maybe they're doctors lawyers doctors
just because you're attractive doesn't
mean you also don't have all these other
things that you want to do in life it's
exactly it should never be mutually
exclusive and that's what I think it
seems like they're trying to make it is
there a real rivalry between the Miss
America people and the Miss USA people I
saw that the joke has always been Miss
America is the girl next door Miss USA
is the girl you wish live next door so
there's definitely a rivalry still all
right you're gonna be a huge success
it's a great day